[Music]
a lawmaker in the philippines has filed
a bill seeking to declare the act of
ghosting
or ending communication with someone
with without explanation a form of
emotional abuse
there should be some kind of
repercussion for people to break my
heart
believe that you should get up scot-free
should pay the price
[Laughter]
i break the ice you pay the price
[Laughter]
a representative guys
representative believes that ghosting
causes trauma as it develops feelings of
rejection and negro and uh and neglect
uh studies have shown that social
rejection of any kind activates the same
pain pathways in the brain as physical
pain meaning there's a biological link
between rejection hi
john ryan believe that
john right
jr because the things they say about
sticks and stones it's true
that is honestly how you feel actually
sticks in stones and they need to make i
have been saying for hundreds of years
make that legislation
[Laughter]
he says it can be like into a form of
emotional cruelty it should be punished
as an emotional offense what is
considered ghosting like if you don't
respond in 24 hours or two days or when
i was sitting at jollibee
i was sitting at the jollibee and uh i
was waiting for my girlfriend and she's
never showed up
never but her clothes showed up but this
was like there's no person
because even you could ghost on text
right yeah that's probably what he means
so if you so what is ghosting let's say
someone was just taking the [ __ ] they
couldn't get back to you and don't
answer back
like is that ghosting no they completely
disappeared very beginning of this video
i defined it
you did yeah yeah but i'll do it again
what is it something
but nick nick wasn't paying attention
ending communication with someone
without explanation yeah but for how
long though forever dude indefinitely
when they just don't respond when you
die and turn into a ghost you don't come
back to life hey bart how do you define
ending [ __ ]
[Laughter]
that means they have to have a period of
time before they can press charges right
like it's gotta be like a year or two oh
okay i see what you say yeah cause it's
like if they panic after three hours
that's not really ghosts yeah yeah
that's true they were taking the [ __ ]
hey there are people like that today
eight hours let's say that
48 hours 48.
i was seeing this chick and i left my
phone at home for once and i went in to
like the office or whatever and by the
time i got home it's like [ __ ] 60
miss tax and [ __ ] holy [ __ ] i was so
worried about you and i was like yeah
well there should be charges for stuff
like that too
stalking for like too much harassment
the opposite of going is that in the
legislation jr yeah that's clause 2. i'm
like i know this dick is [ __ ] magic
but let's calm down please there should
be a text limit right you can't just
keep going like hey are you there are
you there are you there dude are you
there if t-mobile had a feature like
that where they said only with t-mobile
when we feel like you're getting an
excessive amount of text we're just
gonna cut that person off it should be
like when you try to sign in and you
forgot your password and then after a
while they're like you try to attempt
too many times you gotta chill the [ __ ]
sometimes i don't like that though
you're bugging steve green a little too
much i'm the obsessive guy that texts so
i don't like this idea yeah there's i i
would like i would prefer many texts
over being ghosted i'll tell you that
hey come here come here and read this
like that come here
they should call it like so in the
interview with cnn philippines
tabos the the lawmakers also explain the
emotional abuse caused by ghosting is
also detrimental to the nation's
productivity
okay okay if you're a worker that is not
in good state of mind
your work will be affected because you
have been ghosted
with your face
thank you thank you you're welcome he
also added that he he did not indicate
any any proposed penalty as he needs to
consult his colleagues in further
refining the measure his colleagues
ghost him
see see
they're like jr's [ __ ] annoying dude
like bro it's you you're the problem man
just so annoying
i like how he took it all the way up to
government though yeah dude somebody has
to do something he says for me the
offense should not be heavy we can
impose a penalty of community service
for offenders to realize that ghosting
is not right that is not right so so
he's really looking for at the very
least to be like i'm formally ending
conversations with you because i don't
want to continue
i think people who ghost are
uh just childish they don't know how to
communicate but then like no one's
really obligated to communicate with you
either it's it's the freedom of no
speech at all
see there it is it's the freedom of
bailing dude that goes people all the
time dude oh yeah we know yeah yeah yeah
yeah you go when you when you get
ghosted though when somebody goes to you
it's a pretty clear indicator though you
know what i mean yeah
done no but sometimes they run out of
batteries so i go to their house to
double check
that's like a little gsp little filipino
ideas not bad i don't know what happens
like people will get to you when they'll
get to you like if it's like they're not
idiots they saw your task text and then
if they forgot because they're busy then
they're probably dealing with other [ __ ]
and you're not important what if you're
like dating them though and like you
know you you think you have like a they
might dicks in another mouth already you
go to the parent house
no it is it probably is and then she
comes back like dude like i was just
snorkeling it was only one hour what the
[ __ ] and i'm like sorry that's when the
time thing goes if a bar was saying i
got i got true story i got dumped one
time it was awful and then um
you know pretty quickly i was like okay
uh yeah i've got this breakup and then
this chick just [ __ ] pounced on me
out of nowhere right she's super cool
she's like a [ __ ] model and [ __ ] that
was kind of kind of sick and then my ex
was like not a model at all i had no
right to even ever [ __ ] even be near
a modeling agency should have been
probably forcibly removed from anywhere
near modeling agency shouldn't be
allowed to park near there okay
so she
finds out that i'm with this new chick
dude steve green baby and then she gets
[ __ ] starts going crazy starts
[ __ ] texting me calling me calling
call me yeah and then me and this new
chick are out and like she goes back to
my place we [ __ ]
hard i take her [ __ ] like for the
first time ever she's quivering
you know what i mean and that was our
first atm experience too whoa
thank you no so we're we're like asleep
right like this is like hours later
we're asleep
and then all of a sudden this chick
she's like steve steve somebody's here
somebody's [ __ ] oh my god this is
like 3 45 in the morning oh my god
there's a ghost and she's knocking on a
door
she's in my apartment and i'm like you
get to get the [ __ ] out of here i take
her outside and walk her to her car and
watch her again yeah yeah yeah
send her off yeah you so you throw the
model away
i chucked the model like she was
laughing you gotta [ __ ] escape she's
crazy
so so i just i just harangued her i was
like yo what the [ __ ] and she's like
crying despondent i'm like you dumped me
what the [ __ ] you dumped me hard
like you know like dude you're the man
so what the [ __ ] is that i did yeah she
helped you i wasn't even wearing the
money suit back she wouldn't set a
chance now
is it a possession thing i think it was
like a
it was like an insecurity thing because
this new girl is better much prettier
than her whatever in her mind you know
what i mean like some clearly upgrade
yeah right and so that she couldn't
handle because i was supposed to like go
[ __ ] crawl into a gutter and just
like yeah you didn't follow the
narrative yeah i like i said it's
prettier like in her mind even though
she had no right being in the parking
lot
well that's the that's the fun that's
the security removed
my friend's going through something
similar when i'm in i'm in his his uh
ex-wife [ __ ] cheated on him all this
stuff and she's like oh yeah we're so
much happier without being together or
whatever she leaves right and then she's
like in this like she's with the love of
her life whatever and then so
he gets with the mutual friend right and
then she's like
blasting everybody saying like can you
believe he's with her he's been grooming
her can you believe he's like the age
difference is disgusting and i'm like
she's in her early 30s
what the [ __ ] do you mean by grooming
like how could you groom a 30 year old
yeah yeah pretty easy it's like are you
[ __ ] out of your mind and then like
i'm like i thought you were with the
love of your life now and you're both
happy why do you have to go back and
like [ __ ]
try to ruin what he's got yeah and i'm
like that's why what kind of person does
that that's so weird you can't just be
happy they have to be miserable yeah
yeah and then they they could laugh at
their ex and be like
and then they're like i'm having the
greatest time of my life it's like
steve's misery was supposed to be a part
of his ex's coping mechanism and without
that she can't [ __ ] move on but
what's [ __ ] up is she's the one that
broke up with him in the same situation
with my friend but then she had the
confidence to break up with him because
she put him at a specific point yeah
that was her expectation and then now
that he's [ __ ] here she's like oh
yeah once he rebranded
bro she didn't think i'd butterfly out
of that [ __ ] that's what i do every
[ __ ] time yeah you just get better
i've been across crypto again yeah
that's why i'm ruining it out again yeah
dude money suit and all babies setting
it all up the deck is set it's just like
the market has to come to me and watch
it will it's gonna every time i'm
reminded that you're wearing this like
how did i stop seeing it
it is it's just like we're getting used
to it and then i just go off because
it's one of those things where if you
look close enough you're going to see an
optical illusion
what's the optical illusion your big
dick well it is big it is a dick
it's worthy for him it's [ __ ] late in
the day y'all
you